if you ask anyone any person from any
culture any part of the world to
describe what death looks like most
people will immediately jump to a
depiction of the grim reaper and rightly
so the reaper has long been the
personification of death and decay an
omen of demise the cloak skeleton
bearing a sharp scythe coming to collect
souls and carrying them off to either
heaven or hell for centuries human
beings have thought of the grim reaper
as death itself but he's more of an
embodiment of it a symbol meant to
represent that all too familiar fear of
not knowing what lies beyond life on
this fragile mortal plane of existence
death itself the real death looks
completely different welcome to the
story of scp-001
now first things first to anyone
familiar with the scp foundation you
will most likely know that there are
multiple scp-001s
you might even think that you know which
of them is the real one but for those of
you who are new here allow us to clarify
for you this important context the
designation of scp-001
does not refer to a single creature
object or entity but rather a collection
of various anomalies that are allegedly
kept contained by the scp foundation now
there are multiple explanations as to
why these various files are all
collected under the shared designation
of scp-001
one explanation could be that this is
because these anomalies are some of the
earliest ever contained by the
foundation by this rationale all the
scp-001
share the same designation because they
were first encountered before the scp
foundation established the numbering
system that it currently uses however
there also exists a theory that this is
nothing more than intentional
misdirection if we choose to believe
this explanation then it could mean that
the many different
scp-001s are a devious ploy by the
foundation themselves in the interest of
maintaining secrecy and security having
many files sharing the name scp-001
could be the foundation's way of keeping
the nature of the true first scp a
closely guarded secret it seems
plausible that the multiple scp-001
files could be an attempt by the
foundation to conceal information after
all it wouldn't be the first time this
secretive organization deceived someone
so what exactly is this particularly
morbid take on scp-001
well first you have to have a pretty
high level of security clearance within
the scp foundation if you want to even
come close to accessing this file in
fact any and all details about the
anomaly codenamed dead men is protected
by helen stick an aic used by the
foundation's overwatch command also
known as the o5 council an aic for those
who are not yet aware is an advanced
form of artificial intelligence that the
foundation develops and uses to run
parts of its archive of anomalies what
does that mean for scp-001 well it's
pretty simple the people in charge of
the foundation want this file to remain
secure or it could be because the o5
council is hiding something something
that the general staff members aren't
meant to know about getting past all the
additional security surrounding this
particular file we learned that
scp-001 or this one at least is an old
man an 84 year old man to be precise
wait that's it that's what the big
closely guarded secret is just some old
guy no of course he's not just some old
guy the foundation's highest ranking
members wouldn't go through such trouble
over one ordinary man this particular
man has become one with death not the
reaper no
death itself the very concept of death
has been merged with this individual a
lot more interesting than just a normal
old man right to be clear this man is
not an incarnation or embodiment of
death like the grim reaper instead he
has become a vessel for the process of
making something that was once alive
not so this old man
scp-001 can control life and death not
quite
the old man's body is more like a way
that death itself can be influenced it
may help to picture it like this imagine
scp-001
as a television remote control for death
except instead of pressing buttons like
you would on a remote you have to remove
or alter parts of the old man's body and
in doing so you can manipulate the
process of death albeit only to a
limited extent you can't for example
permanently stop death from existing or
occurring stopping everyone around the
world from dying that's not quite how
scp-001 works here let's give you an
example
scp-001 had his tongue removed as well
as had sustained damage to his eardrums
before he was contained by the
foundation so as a result of those
alterations to his body there are fewer
deals with death events in the modern
era you see what we mean now changing
scp-001 changes how death functions but
doesn't necessarily stop it from
happening so in essence although there
are parameters
scp-001 is the foundation's way of
controlling death itself how did they
decide to go about doing this well once
we tell you you will understand why the
o5 council wanted to keep information
about
scp-001 such as secret after performing
a series of complex brain surgeries and
various other procedures on the old man
the overwatch command intentionally
engineered him to be unable to perceive
certain people who were those people you
guessed it the o5 council themselves
making scp-001 unable to recognize the
faces of any o5 council members means
that death is unable to see or perceive
the council members either all those
pieces fit together to form a
particularly unsettling jigsaw puzzle by
tampering with scp-001 the o5 council
have made themselves effectively
immortal they cannot die nor will they
age or decay like normal mortal human
beings death still occurs of course
other beings can die but the council
members are exempt from that fundamental
law of nature the foundation believes
that scp-001 was initially created by an
occult group known as the eternal circle
thanks to records recovered from the
circle's london headquarters the scp
foundation now knows that they were the
ones responsible for merging the old man
with the concept of death when their
personnel first recovered scp-001
the old man was frail in a poor physical
condition and barely responded to any
external stimuli research staff believe
he must have suffered severe trauma at
the hands of the eternal circle
evidenced by the circular symbols that
had been carved into his back oh and
also the fact that his body parts had
all been modified contained within the
file for this scp-001
is a letter directly from the o5 council
themselves explaining their reasons for
using the old man to become immortal
they justify their actions by claiming
that they have a wealth of experience in
containing anomalies and keeping the scp
foundation running this is to them a
perfectly valid reason to make
themselves exempt from death rather than
aging retiring and dying to later be
replaced by new members on the overwatch
council they claim that their
immortality is not for their own
self-benefit of course but for the good
of the foundation as an organization and
by extension the world as a whole the
council also promised that the same
death exempt status would later be
extended to other vital members of
personnel however according to the
hellenistic aic guarding the file no
personnel have been considered for death
exempt status in the future in other
words the o5 council were lying and
intended to keep their get out of death
free card to themselves it wasn't long
before the foundation's very own ethics
committee learned about what the council
was up to and naturally they had some
concerns according to a report issued by
committee chairman odongo tajani the way
the o5 council were using scp-001 to
prolong their own lives was immoral and
inhumane even by their own strange
standards by using this poor frail old
man for their own gain the council had
warped the natural way death should work
and threatened to anomalously unbalance
the very laws of nature the ethics
committee had no other choice but to
dispatch its own mobile task force known
as omega 1 or the law's left hand to
rectify the situation their mission to
detain all members of the o5 council at
their next meeting removing them from
office and replacing them with
high-ranking candidates from within the
foundation's lower ranks finally they
also plan to neutralize scp-001
cleaning house and removing the
temptation for future council members to
make themselves immortal in short this
was a coup the o5 council was going to
be overthrown by their own ethics
committee of course the council was more
than prepared for this and also had
their very own mobile task force on hand
to defend them against the plot alpha
one also known under the code name red
right hand the legendary lackeys of the
o5 council clash with the law's left
hand it is believed that the shadowy
administrator of the scp foundation also
had his own personal task force possibly
reish one also called the seat of
consciousness enter the fray in other
words we were looking at an absolutely
insane three-way foundation civil war
bloodbath how exciting security footage
showed these three groups engaged in a
firefight within site-01 using
foundation training and tactics against
each other in what would probably be the
most epic battle of all of their lives
it was absolute chaos the air thick with
screams and gunsmoke cameras also picked
up a group of men and women lying all
around site-01 many wounded but still
alive impressive given how many of them
had taken gunshots right to their heads
that's right these were presumed to be
the members of the o5 council still
unable to die despite being shot it is
unclear which of the mtfs were
responsible for this the ethics
committee had only intended law's left
hand to secure the council members it
could well be that they were caught in
the crossfire that occurred as the law's
left hand and red right-hand teams
fought unless of course the
administrator's task force were the ones
who had stepped in and shot the o5
council through all the chaos that had
unfurled scp-001
was still in this cell and he wasn't
alone an unknown figure had somehow
gained access and he conversed with
scp-001
the man went on to tell scp-001 that the
foundation was wrong to tamper with the
nature of death and recounted a story he
said that he had once filed paperwork
regarding anomalies for an unknown
organization but couldn't live with the
horror of what his job entailed so the
man sold these files to a group of 13
individuals the 05 council they then
went on to form a full organization the
scp foundation as we know it the man
then stated that he was disgusted with
how the foundation had used as cp-001
how the council members had engineered
the frail old man to make themselves
immortal he had hoped that they would be
a force for good keeping any necessary
evil to a minimum the unknown figure
told scp-001 that the conflict between
the council and the ethics committee had
happened many times before with many
other versions of the old man earlier
scp-001s previously merged with the
concept of death he then helped
scp-001 identify the members of the
council ending their immortality
promising the weak tired old man that
he'd finally be able to rest the unknown
mystery man claimed that he would always
be in power the 05 council would always
bring him back after all he was their
figurehead their leader the scp
foundation administrator himself in the
end the administrator himself chose to
let himself perish too perhaps in shame
of what his organization had become or
did he because someone seems to have
been accessing the helen stick aic and
the scp-001 file using his login since
this incident maybe the hand of death
doesn't reach quite as far as we were
led to believe and that's where the tale
of scp-001
ends a story of the foundation's greed
and their pursuit of eternal life we
mustn't forget that death isn't
something to be afraid of after all it
gives our lives meaning knowing that
they will one day end but when you look
at the kind of monsters we can become in
the pursuit of eternal life well in the
words of another wise old man sometimes
dead is better now go check out
scp-001 which is the real zero zero one
and scp-001 when day breaks for more on
the mysterious scp-001